France beat Croatia in the final in Moscow by four goals to two,...
...a game laden with historical significance.
These are the scenes on the Champs Elysees in the French capital right now.
It is quite an epic sight,...
...countless French men and women celebrating for as far as the eye can see,...
...a picture very reminiscent of 1998 when Les Bleus won their first world title...
...in a tournament that they were hosting.
And now, 20 years on, they have done it again.
An extraordinary match won by extraordinary players...
...against a very strong side as you can see,...
...the French can't quite believe it.
When they made it past the semifinals on it, it seemed so remarkable already...
...that they should've made it that far.
They knew they had a strong squad,...
...but there were so many other strong sides still in the match.
And now, they've done it,...
...20 years after their 1998 win,...
...and with a team of many youngsters who didn't even remember it...
...or too young to remember it.
Some of them weren't even born.
They've now done it again...
...and that World Cup will be coming back to France.